Okay. Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 2nd,
2012 what's going on?
It's the first week of July.
Oh my God.
This summer is just flying by.
I can't,
can you believe it?
Can you believe that it's gets July?
Can you believe that we spend all of
June going? Can you believe it's June?
Hey people say that even though
I make fun of it all the time,
which probably annoys the shit out of you,
but I hate people who fucking
live in the past, you know?
Like what did you think that you
were going to achieve in June yet?
How did you get a sunburn? Good.
Well then it was a good month. Yes.
Time is flying by. Yes, you
are going to fucking die.
So why don't you quit sitting around
talking about how it's going by and why
don't you go do something?
Huh?
Hypothetical person that I
never even heard say this shit.
Do you know there's allegedly an asteroid?
Not allegedly and I guess there is
an asteroid. I mean five fucking no,
there isn't one. Cause now like I have
a telescope, it's Goddamn scientist.
I think they do that just so they
can keep, they can have a job.
They just look through this giant
telescope. Nobody else looks through it.
What'd you seek? Doug is an
asteroid 10 right? Torches man,
it's going to kill everybody
unless you give us $4 billion,
but you're fucking nerds. That's I think
the scientists that that level did that.
Just like bankers at that level,
just complete corrupt pieces of shit.
You know, every once in a while
you'll see a good one. Yeah.
You meet an honest one that'll sit
there and be like, you know, ah,
I don't know what to tell you.
We've pretty much mapped out all the
way to the end of the universe. Had A,
I still have just as many questions is
when I started, which once again is why,
uh,
that,
that poor metea so whatever the fuck
it was called was such a good movie.
I can't remember the names.
Um, so anyways, it's supposed
to be habit dentally.
There's this asteroid heading
right towards us, you know,
and rather than just letting it happen,
you know,
and just ending the fucking movie.
W W we're going to send some shit up
there to try to land on it and make fuck
with its trajectory. We're going to,
we can shoot some stuff at it and then,
and then what?
And then what?
We're going to keep living until we
destroy the entire fucking atmosphere and
just make this whole place unlivable.
All right, we're done. It's over.
Did you ever go to a fucking,
uh,
like Vegas or you go to Atlantic City
and you look up on a billboard and you
like, that motherfucker is still doing
shows. What is he doing? It's over.
Nobody fucking cares.
Go fucking out and make your own jam.
You know your own Jelly and
start a start a new business.
No one wants to fucking listening to
sing that God damn song that was a hit in
1974 the day Libya they die.
Do you imagine that poor
bastard sing and that,
so he's even still alive if he's
dead is because of that song.
And I have to sing that
for 40 fucking years.
And they would say good or Madonna did
a cover that then she did she do a house
version, some gay guys with
some tied off shirts behind her,
making it new yet keeping it old.
Um,
she's uh, you know what's amazing about
her cause she continued to work out,
you know, it's fucking incredible.
Her body is like, you know,
just like a fucking 18 year old with
this from reason. The can't, you can't,
uh, work out on your face.
There's no like face pull ups
and I don't give a fuck if you get that
faceless shit and everything, you know,
you still look old. You just
can't, you can't fucking beat it.
Which is why you don't sit around going,
oh my God, it's fucking July already.
Uh, with your bud light and your cigarette
shut your face, your freckled whore. Um,
I live in the past a lot. I do every
morning when I take my dog for a walk,
I listened to fucking music and half the
time I'm fan, I'm always fantasizing.
That's me singing it and playing like,
do you guys do that shit? Like you're a,
like the, you know, like a utility
infielder that can like play any position.
Like I can play every instrument when
I'm listening to the song and whoever is
the standout in that moment of the song
by the borough, there'd be the singer,
the or the fucking tambourine player,
whatevers steel. And my focus,
that's who I am.
And half the time I'm doing it 30 years
ago and my high school auditorium and
the whole school is going,
wow, that guy is awesome.
And every once in a while I'll actually
step out of the fantasy and go, Bill,
you know, there's really something fucking
wrong with you. And then I just laugh,
you know, Oh, I throw my head back and I
cackle and then my dog looks at me like,
what the fuck is wrong with you? And
then she takes a shit and I pick it up.
That's my morning time.
My morning works,
then they come back and I make myself
a little breakfast. Um, underrated.
Fucking,
it's such a Boston's fucking cooking,
cooking for yourself. And even more
underrated cooking for your friends.
I actually, uh, I worked with
Kevin Shea, fucking hilarious.
Jason Lawhead Cleveland Zone. And
that's not a lie. That's the truth.
Cleveland zone.
Jason Lawhead who just grown by leaps
and bounds keeps getting funnier.
And uh, I actually, I made those
guys at dinner before we went out,
before we went out to, uh,
Ontario, the inland empire.
I was teasing them all, fuck
a weekend about that name.
The fucking inland empire.
Who Do you guys plan on conquering
next? Just saying shit like that. Um,
it's really is impressive bad ass name
cause I think they actually call
it the I e which is really bad.
You should just call it the inland empire.
You know,
when you just have a regular
name like Pittsburgh,
you got to come up with something to try
to like jazz it up. Like, you know, when,
when you come into the Berg, when
he coming to be more, you know,
and it's, yeah. Oh, I always said
that most corniest joke ever.
Can you be more douchey? Ugh, really?
Fuck you. It's Monday morning.
I'm entitled to that. Um,
oh, you live in a place,
it's the inland empire. You
don't, you don't have to fucking,
you don't have to make up a name.
Do you want that fucking reminds me of,
I remember a long time ago at the height,
at the tail end of the height of
that fucking deaf jam style of,
of standup comedy where you could
just talk about white people,
like they were borderline retarded and
white people would just sit there and
laugh even though none of it made sense.
And you could even relate to it,
but the political correctness
needle was at its peak. So you,
you just felt like you had to
laugh because if you didn't,
then you were maybe
some roundabout racist.
Do you remember that or
is this just my world? Um,
I saw this one man show on Broadway and
this guy was doing this whole bit and he
goes, yeah, me and my, all my
friends, this Latin dude, he goes,
me and my friends would go, we'd go
into Maddie Hattie. And then he goes,
that's Manhattan for all you white people.
And everybody laughed.
It's like I that just right there,
I just zoned out of it.
That whole fucking show. It's
like, fuck you. You can't,
you think I can't figure that out.
Like that's some sort of like you like
you're some Apache and I'm the god
Japanese and I can't break the
fucking code. I'm in Manhattan.
You're dumb cunt. It's not like
I'm watching this and Kentucky.
I'm in fucking Manhattan.
Uh,
Jesus Christ fucking remixed the
name of this God Damn Town Aman.
And it is a town.
Manhattan is a town.
I know it's a bunch of
people there and everything,
but it's really fucking
small with no traffic.
You can drive from one end to the
other and like 10 minutes. I mean,
you're hauling ass, but you can do it on
the, on the, on the highways on the side.
Me Do that with any fucking
town out there. Right.
And he's got everybody jammed
together and fucking, you know,
shooting up into the sky.
That's the thing about New York,
I told you that before is,
is like you got to eat.
You should live there at
some point in your life.
And do it sooner rather than later.
Do it.
And like your 20s and then a little bit
in de [inaudible] and then get the fuck
out. That's perfect.
That's fucking perfect.
I was just talking to Neil about that this
morning. We were cracking up about it,
like how we got to, I mean, I
actually stayed there too long,
but God out at the right time, you know
what I mean? You know it is about man,
you just can't get any fucking privacy.
Everybody's just jammed in
with each other. And then like,
you don't give a fuck when you're young,
when you can go out and drink until
fucking three in the morning, wake up,
still have abs and go to work at
seven in the morning, you know,
to fuck with some third world countries,
economy or whatever the hell it is.
Those constitute down a Wall
Street. Right. You can do that,
but fucking you start getting
into your thirties and it's,
you just can't do it anymore and you just
want to come home and you want fucking
space age. You want quiet, you know,
he can't fucking sit there.
And then there's going to be some new 20
something year old moving in next year.
He's going to be fucking rage and for
three years and going through breakups and
fucking screaming at fucking
girlfriends and all that crap.
And then there's going to be the person
down the hall that's like 10 years older
than you all right? And you're starting
to see them slipping into that, you know,
getting a few too many pets and
I'm becoming like a Gora phobic,
you know what I mean? It just gets
depressing after a while. So now it's,
now it's great. I could live out
here and then I'll come back there.
I'll do a Gig, I hang for like a week
and then I get the fuck out of there.
But I got to admit when I go into the, the
comedy clubs, it's fuck, it's horrific.
I walk in and I'm looking
for familiar faces.
My eyebrows are up and I'm looking
around and there's nobody there that I
remember anymore. And I, I,
it fucking kills me. It's,
it's why I hate going home to my hometown.
I hate it because I moved away
so long ago when I called back,
it's like a fucking time warp and I think
I'm going to walk around town seeing
people that I know and,
and I don't see anybody.
And then maybe you run into somebody that
you do know and hopefully they'd been
going to the gym because if they haven't,
they're going to quickly remind
you how fucking old you are.
And I swear to God at that
point, I want to kill myself. Um,
then what the fuck do I do?
How do I get out of that?
Depression has been my whole, I don't,
what the fuck is in my throat here?
Hang on a second. Hang on one
second. I got to fucking hang on.
All right,
I'm back to hit pause there.
One of the rare times they
have to hit the pause button.
I just went outside and
just, I just, you know,
hawked it up and just spit all over
these plants. And second I did it.
I started laughing because I know the
plants were just like, fuck really?
You know, plants, poor bastards.
You know, what sucks about being
a plant is you can't fucking,
you can't move. You
can't like, you know, Oh,
here comes some fucking spittle and
just sorta like slip a punch. Yeah.
I think that's what sucks about
being a plant plant is you can't,
you can't slip a punch. There would
be my number one reason, you know,
and then just sitting there and a bunch
of fire ants or whatever the fuck they
are.
Some sort of insect locusts just start
eating you and you just sitting there,
you know, it's like you got
fucking cement shoes on. You know,
I bet after this fucking astroid Ma,
if it mercifully hits this fucking planet,
all right. Ends us and we go
down just like the dinosaurs,
like I think plants are going to take
over next and there's going to be a big
moment in their life when one of them
finally has the sense to pull leg part of
their roots out of the ground and
just move over a couple inches,
then they'll gradually the
grow feet, right? And then,
uh,
once they do that,
then you'll probably have your
first like hand to hand combat
somebody gonna get raped,
you know,
and then they'll invent some stuff and
then they'll think that they're special
and then they'll invent this
invisible guy in the sky.
And then they'll fight over who has
the right visible guy and then another
asteroid is going to hit.
That's what I think keep happening.
I think God just keeps making shit and
waiting for people to fucking figure it
out. And he just keeps going at God.
These ones that dumped too, right?
You have anything like what
he's doing on this planet is,
it's like somebody trying to
build a hot rod, you know,
and we're like the transmission and we
just keep slipping and they just have
fucked us.
You know what?
This doesn't fit this engine and then you
just fucking throws an asteroid at the
God damn thing now.
Well I do anyway.
So I was mentioning earlier that I um,
hang on a second,
get in here,
sit down.
It's fucking dog goes out there. I
don't understand it. She goes out,
I left the door open,
she goes out in the backyard and she
lays in the sun until she's panting.
Like she just ran a marathon. Then
she gets up, drinks a bunch of water,
and then lays in the shade and
then does it all over again.
And then at some point she fucking goes
over and just starts eating the grass,
little blades of grass and it gets
stuck in the back of her throat.
And then she goes for the rest of
the fucking day. Why do you do that?
Huh? What are you going to involve? Where
you can fucking speak to me. All right.
Get over there and lay down.
Please do it. Do as I say,
Hey, what are you going
clear? I'll get over here.
Fucking walk away from me and
my podcasts. Lay Down, down.
Sit. Stop looking at me
like that. All right.
Go outside. Go on. Get out
of here. See that? That's
going to be a horrible parent.
All right. Here's a fucking
ice cream. Um, anyways.
Yes. So cooking for somebody
is fucking great. It's, you
know what I love about it?
That there's a rush that comes as,
as they're coming over, you know,
you're trying to time it
so it's fucking perfect.
You try and make it look good and then
there's this panic that you're going to
fuck it up and that there's going to be
this awkward silence because it's sucks.
Right. And this is thing I'm cooking
for two comedians, so if it's sucks,
they're going to tell me,
especially that cunt, Kevin Shay,
he doesn't give a fuck that guy.
You know, Kevin, by the way, is,
is an unbelievable singer,
but he's embarrassed. Um,
I dunno. He has like this
hidden talent. Like he fucking,
I caught him one time when I walked in
the green room. He was sitting by himself.
I thought he had the fucking right
radio one. He's unbelievable.
So a ladies get them to sync for you
when you go and see him out on the road.
Kevin Shea, s. H. E. A.
Um, so anyways, I fucking,
uh, yeah, there's like this rush. Like,
are they gonna are they gonna like it?
I think, I think it sucks. And, uh,
fortunately I pulled it off
and they loved it and uh,
I didn't get trashed by them the
entire fucking way out there.
That would have been a long drive. Who
the fuck told you you could cook? Um,
you listen to the Monday morning podcast,
everybody,
I hope you're having a good
Monday settling into the
July 4th weekend or middle
of the week then don't you hate when
like the Jill July 4th. What's it,
what's it a Wednesday second therefore?
Yeah, Wednesday. Ah, they fuck shit.
You know what I mean?
Cause if it's a Tuesday,
if it lands on a Tuesday or a Thursday,
maybe they'll give you that
Monday or that Friday off.
You could somehow get a 40 fucking
weekend out of it. Or even still,
even if they don't give you the
Friday, he just go Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday you get fucking Thursday
off you dick around on Friday,
you still half cocked from
the fucking barbecue. Right.
And then it's the weekend.
It's a great fucking time.
But when it falls on the Wednesday,
those cons make you come in Monday,
Tuesday you'd take a little bit of break.
Then Thursday, Friday ag, you know,
you still getting a day off out of it,
but you know,
you know what I mean?
When it lands on that Monday or
Atlanta on that fucking Friday. Okay.
My world, that's America.
If I was president July 4th
would always be on a Monday.
Definitely. Definitely would
be on a Monday every fucking
year. And people that,
well, you know, that actually lands
on the seventh and I'd be like, Hey,
who picks up the red phone? Mya? You
all right? Go Fuck yourself then. Okay,
it's on the seventh this year.
Do we even know that they
signed it on the fucking forth?
Do we fourscore and seven years ago,
does somebody really say that?
Do you have any fucking
idea? Oh, by the way,
I actually saw a Abraham Lincoln
vampire hunter this past week and a,
I got to tell you,
um,
I got tickets for free before you think
I'm the dumbest person on the planet.
But I actually had faith in that
movie because I was like, all right,
there has to be a reason they made this
because this just seems like the most
ridiculous idea I've
ever heard in my life.
And I went and I saw it and
there was really no surprise.
It was exactly what I thought
it was going to be. A,
it was just a vampire hunter who
happened to be Abraham Lincoln
and they just invented all of this
shit. I'm sure it was a book. Maybe.
I don't think it was. It was like
some nerd shit and I shouldn't have,
I shouldn't have seen it.
Yeah,
I was all right.
I was drinking when I saw it.
I was fucking hammered by the end of it.
You know what I mean?
It's like when your team goes down 11
runs fucking two winnings and you're like,
Eh, fuck. It might as well drink. What
are we going to do? Go home to a wife.
Um,
you know,
it was the worst part was it was in three
d and I fucking hate three d movies.
I really hate it.
That's just that right there.
When a movies in three d that is a very
secretive little fucking nod and a wink
going, hey, hey, this movie
sucks. This movie sucks so bad.
We had to make shit float around
you to keep it mildly entertaining.
I Hate Three d and You know what
sucks about three d now is they?
Fuck they're making shit in three d
that doesn't even need to be in three d,
You know, back in the day. All right,
Friday the 13th part three in three d,
You know we shot that fucking Arrow
when it comes at you. All right, cool.
That was cool. But like nowadays
the guy's like, Abraham,
here's your pen and the
guy just reads hands a pen.
Why is that in three d?
Am I supposed to say? Wow.
It was almost like he was
handing that pen to me,
that thing that actually happens to me
in real life that happens to me in real
life.
A guy with the hockey mask on shooting
an Arrow at me does not fucking happen
near a lake or not near a lake. It doesn't
fucking happen. Make that in three d.
Don't just have somebody sitting at a
fucking desk in three d so I feel like I'm
in the office. Oh, it's so fucking
stupid. You know what I mean?
I don't even, what the fuck I'm saying
anymore? Um, you know what, how about,
how about a little bit of advertising,
a little bit of advertising. How cheese.
I have to keep putting the
fucking password in this.
Why do I have to have a password on my
computer as if what I'm doing on this
thing is so God damn important.
Top secret. What is the password?
What is the password? We can't have the
world have access to your shit jokes.
All right. Um, no,
I'm in the wrong area here or in
the wrong area. Find it. Find it.
Here it is. Okay. Quick advertising.
Only two, only two this week, right?
amazon.com everybody.
Hey,
do you go to amazon.com
and you buy yourself some
Freddie Mercury tank tops and
dance around your bathroom. You know,
sweating it up, right? Well. Um,
if you'd like to donate to my podcast
and the wounded warrior project,
just go to [inaudible] dot
com click on the podcast page.
Take your pretty little eyes,
scan over to the right.
You're going to see the Amazon,
uh, banner. You Click on that,
it brings you right to Amazon and then
purchase to your heart is fulfilled.
You don't have to buy anything. I'm not
saying that there's no pressure here.
This is a soft sell.
I'm leaning back right now.
I've got my hands up in the air like,
Hey, you know, I didn't touch him. I said,
this is how the sound doing
this wholesales. Think, okay,
so don't feel like I'm pressuring you.
You can walk right out of the showroom.
I'm all right with it. I made myself
a Turkey sandwich and an apple.
I'll take my lunch.
It doesn't raise the price or anything.
You buy whatever you want on Amazon and
then they kick a percentage back up to
me and I take 10% of that. I give it an
an I rounded up to the nearest hundred.
I'm going to actually
kick in some even more,
but I've been doing all right
lately and it's just a great cause.
It makes you feel good. So, um, if
you, if you do it, God bless you.
If you don't, I understand
hands are up. Hey,
that trying to make you do anything
you don't want, sir. Ma'Am, Sonny boy.
All right.
Advertising number two game
fly.com [inaudible] dot com
are you sick of the real
world and want to disappear in 8,000
video games where you're a hero instead of
the person you truly are.
We all do.
Listen gamefly fly.com 8,000
videos and it's insane.
They'll mail them to
your home or the bridge,
take them directly to your PC and
when you'd done pit playing them,
you can mail them back
in the process continues.
Monthly fees are a fraction of
what a new game costs. Yeah.
This is why this totally makes sense
because once you're done with the game,
nine times out of 10, what are
you, what is it? What do you do?
It's just more clutter.
It's just another stack of crap.
You have to put in a box when you go to
move. All right? This is, that was what,
this is what I would do if I was a
Gamer. All right? If I was a Gamer,
I would go do gamefly.com
I play all those games.
I'd send back all the ones that I'm
done with and I don't care about,
and then the special ones,
I just buy those be perfect.
Then I get to sample everything.
You know what I mean?
It's like finding a wife and you've
got 8,000 women coming, right?
You get to hook up with all of them.
This is like what what they promised to
terrorists and you don't even have to
blow yourself up, is one of the
greatest things ever. It, uh,
the games fit playstation,
Xbox, we and even your PC, uh,
for Monday morning podcast listeners,
uh, you get a free two disk,
15 day trial, that's a $23
value. That's all it costs.
That's almost free,
but 15 days free,
8,000 all the ladies you want.
That's a metaphor for games by going
to www.game fly.com/burr or through the
banner ad on Bill [inaudible] dot
com slash podcast page. All righty.
There you go.
And that's the advertising for this week.
Wasn't that painless by the way,
by the way?
I think it's time. I think we're about
17 minutes in and think it's about time.
I patted myself on the back. How
about that? Download speed last week.
Huh? How about that? I
didn't hear any complaining.
You know, hundreds and hundreds
of people bitch, Moan and,
and fuck woo woo woo.
Right?
So I finally fixed the God damn
problem and what have I get?
I get like five tweets going,
hey, I really appreciate it.
You know what happened in the rest of you?
Cause you went on to bitch
about something else.
You don't like the photo on
my fucking page. You know,
you have a stop and thinking about,
you know,
maybe finding out what you're
really upset about Jesus Christ.
Could I use that advice?
Huh? Um, all right,
let's talk about something in the news.
Shall We? Um, I actually, like I said,
I didn't even watch any TV this week.
This is just a really weird time of the
year for me with the NHL and the NBA
have ended. The NFL hasn't started up
yet. I'll watch a little Wimbledon,
I'll watch it.
A little bit of that World Cup soccer.
I wouldn't fuck you call it the European
Championship. I wrote for Germany.
I'm mostly German,
you know,
I root for those guys who they Lucy,
they're lost to Italy and then Spain
kick the shit out of Italy. Um,
it's great. I can watch any sport
when a championship is on the line.
I don't give a shit what it is.
Cause you,
you feel that energy from the
fucking crowd. You know what I mean?
Like I would go,
like if I was driving by a little league
field and somebody said that was the
championship game of Little League,
I would actually pull over and watch it
from my car. Like a creepy pedophile.
Wow.
No, I would, I would,
I would walk up when I would sit
amongst the parents so they would,
they would not feel uncomfortable.
Um, but like I don't,
I don't, uh, I stopped watching
the news years ago. It just was,
I couldn't watch it anymore. The same
reason why I stopped going to church.
I was just like, this isn't what's
going on with the telling me isn't,
is a guests. I just don't buy
into it, you know, other than,
that's why I like sports.
I like watching ESPN because what
they say is true. For the most part,
the Phillies did win two to one.
There was 30,000 witnesses. They
saw it happen. That other shit,
when you start telling me what's going
on and fuck and Frankford or fucking
Vienna, a God damn fucking Cairo.
I don't, I don't know. Is it,
is that what happened?
Is that footage actually from that,
from that fucking place.
Did that happen this week?
Am I still going to keep asking questions?
Will this ever end? I don't know.
I'm sorry. Well, you know, every once in
awhile I get in one of those in my brain.
It just,
I can't,
I tried to get out of it and then tonight
just it's like somebody else takes it
over.
Do you know what,
what kind of people that do that shit
when they're explaining something to you
and then they start
asking questions for you.
Like if they would teach you how to cook,
you know,
so you put the water in the
pan. Do I bring it to a boil
almost? Do I throw salt?
Salt in? Not necessarily.
And you're like, dude,
who the fuck you talking to at this
point? Oh, he's a nice trick for you,
for your pasta that somebody taught me
your poor little olive oil in there.
It keeps the uh, the pasta from
sticking together. You don't, evidently,
that's what the salt is supposed to do.
I thought it flavored the water.
I didn't realize that was supposed to
help it not stick together. Um, oh,
I made a great fucking meal.
Not going to lie to you.
Not going to fucking lie to you.
Spaghetti and fork and meatballs.
Delish anyways,
it's like I said,
I haven't been watching a lot of shit
on the news. I just don't watch it.
You know what?
I think they shouldn't have to fucking
sing the news the way they do in the
Catholic church.
You know
there was a guy who got attacked
by two monkeys in South Africa.
Okay?
He decided he was going to go down
there and try to rehabilitate some
chimpanzees that had been
abused and they turn around,
dragged them for two kilometers
and kicked the shit outta him.
What a dumb fuck.
Why would you fly across the world
to get your fucking ass kicked?
Did you guys hear about this dude,
South Africa,
Texas student attacked by chimp improves.
Thank God he improves this poor
fucking bastard. He's a ranger, right?
He loves animals.
This is the thing about animal lovers.
You gotta realize that once you go past
a certain level of domestic animal and
you start getting into the wild,
no matter how much you love them,
they're not going to love you back.
Wild animals. I like that. Dick,
you shouldn't have gone out with,
you know,
that person have cheated on you.
That person who just doesn't have your
back. Wild animals do not have your back.
Your dog has your back,
you cat borderline cats kind of have
that creepy vibe that if shit went bad,
they'd decide what the intruder,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Fish. They just don't have
any fucking say. They're like
a Stepford wife, you know?
That's why dogs are the best they,
it's they truly fucking love you.
My Dog fucking loves me.
Will be on a walk and all of
a sudden she just look up me.
It's almost like she's smiling. You
know how fucking warped, why sound?
She's probably just panting and
it looks like she's smiling.
He's probably going like, why does he
have this fucking rope around my neck?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
If I really wanted to,
I could rip his fucking face off,
but in my world I'm so in love with
my dog and look, she's smiling,
but that's not bad when you just have a
dog. I think people who fucking, you know,
okay,
fuck with animals for a wild, wild
animals, they start thinking like, oh,
look at the Cheetah. Oh, she's play
a Gig and all of a sudden draw off.
This fucking launches itself that you
all right.
I believe that we came from monkeys.
I believe that we came from the apes.
I believe something else. So there's
three in a row in this sound smooth.
Um, but I by no means think that, uh,
that those fucking things like us,
I don't give a,
if I teach at sign language and the
chimps sitting at going in sign language,
Hey, I think you're a cool
guy there. Freckled face cunt.
You know that there's no fucking way I'm
ever going on the other side of the God
damn cage.
This poor bastard was on the other.
He was on the other side of the cage.
He just got too close.
That's how fucking insane a
wild animal is. Chimpanzees,
they say have the strength of six,
six men.
This dude got attacked by two chimps
that would be like getting attacked by a
flash mob. Okay? Like 12 fucking people.
They just grabbed this mother fucker
by his ankles. They reached underneath.
I mean, I don't what kind of bullshit cage
they had was like a compound, you know.
So they put up that,
that,
that cheap wire shit when you don't
want to rabbit to come in and eat your
lettuce, right. And your garden.
Like they put that shit up.
So this fucking guy sitting there,
you know as they go doing
that shit and he's like,
what are you guys doing to
tell me we don't tell me right?
And he's trying to sign to them. You
guys want to play Frisbee, right?
And they sitting there talking to
each other going just two more inches,
two more inches. Look at this dumb mother
fucker who wants to play Frisbee, right?
And they reach underneath,
grab him by his fucking ankles,
strike the 12 men. They fucking pull
them right underneath that goddamn thing.
Like when you go to Quiznos and they
stick you sub right through that poor
excuse for a fucking a brick oven
yanked motherfucker right underneath.
Oh my God. And then they dragged him
full like another fucking two kilometers.
However fucking far that is. I
don't know. In my world that's a,
what's that about a mile and a quarter,
cause I know like 40 kilometers,
like 60 kilometers is like 40
miles an hour. Who gives a fuck?
They dragged this son of a bitch basically
through the length of every football
stadium in the NFL and I can guarantee
you it wasn't the nice turf that those
guys play on.
This was the natural habitat.
Like I can't imagine
the vice grip strength,
those, those fucking things, man, they'll
rip your foot off the rip your balls off,
the rip your face off the rip it off.
Like you open a fucking Goddamn thing,
a yogurt,
God damn ice cream when you just take
the lid off, they do that to your face.
What the fuck are you doing near
these God damn things. You know
Jesus fucking Christ.
I would have to tranquilize had guns and
I would be wearing one of those fucking,
you know the suit you wear when you,
you think you're going to get bitten
by a shark. That chain link shit,
there's no fucking way.
There's no way fucking catcher's
mass welded to my face.
I'm not going anywhere in here.
And not only that,
these aren't just regular fucking chimps
that have been swinging around eating
bananas, occasionally eating
another monkey alive, right?
This isn't that shit. These are ones
that were abused. They were fucked with.
Okay.
And having adopted a fucking abused
dog and the Goddamn Skitzo Shit that,
that thing does,
I can't fucking imagine.
Okay?
Uh, a goddamn schizophrenia fucking ate
two of them, straight to 12 God damn men.
And you're going to walk near
the cage trying to sign, hey,
how about the weather frank or whatever
fucking human name you gave him,
your right Yardi a fuck, and God bless
you. Your heart's in the right place.
Fortunately, this kid doesn't seem
like he had any damage like that,
but like this dude was so in shock,
like they were finally able to just
like stitch them up and stabilize him.
And evidently he's not in critical
condition and it doesn't seem like,
it seems like he still has his balls,
his feet and his face,
which is incredible. But
they say, you know, he,
he has bite marks and
a and fractures plural.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Just treating you like a fucking rag doll.
That is the most horrifying
shit in the world. To me,
nature is the most horrifying shit.
I would rather have a lot. Let's see.
You know what, the human equivalent,
someone has to come into my
house with a fucking chainsaw.
I can deal with the Goddamn,
I could deal with the machete.
Alright. I could deal with that.
Chainsaws that, that's hardcore.
I could fuck up machete. I could deal
with, I think I could fucking do the,
the sugar ray Leonard,
you know,
stick my face out and then pull it back
when you took a swing and then fucking
try to take both your legs out.
Uh, only hardcore boxing fans
got that one. Um, but the,
I mean if you were in a room with the
chimp and that thing goes fucking ape
shit, no pun intended. That thing is
on the floor. It's up on the ceiling.
It's across the room.
It's like,
it's like a comment and you're sitting
there dealing with human speed,
dude.
That's why we got the brains that we have.
This why was so much smarter. We have
to be because it was so fucking slow.
You know what I mean?
You ever see a white guy who gets
dunked on and those highlight films,
you know that fucking guy that they bring
off the bench when the teams either up
by 30 or down by 30 that guy,
that's what we are in nature.
Even the fucking athletic humans.
Yet your note, we're nowhere near.
Just think like a how fast a fucking
snake is a fucking pit Viper Viper.
I just nothing fucking, you don't
eat your bit and that thing has left,
left the fucking building
before you even did,
before that signal from
your fucking leg going, hey,
we just got bit by a Goddamn pit
viper even reaches your brain.
That snake is already leaving
and then you go,
and then the real is, and as the
realization did that you got bit hits you,
you are, you're already collapsing.
Why the fuck would you go out there?
Okay.
You know, I, I don't know. We
had to be that fucking smart.
Yeah.
I can't imagine that the God damn fear
back in the fucking day you're walking
around with a bunch of God
damn neanderthals or whatever
it Niana talls I guess
I supposed to say I sit in the under thall
my entire life, but it's neander tall,
I guess. And what else was it? There
was two tribes. One of them died off.
There was an [inaudible] and then
there was the fucking crow magnums.
And I forget what the fuck we are.
One of them, one and the other ones,
the other one of them was a little bit
smarter and the other ones were a little
dumber and dumber ones died off.
All right.
And some people have a little bit of
that Crow Magnum or Neanderthal in him,
you know, because you know
that people, they fuck right.
It's going to be the dumbest
education podcasts you've,
you'll ever got to fucking hair.
I just totally lost my train of thought.
What the fuck was I talking
about? Oh, Niana toss. Right.
So I can't imagine what
can walking around.
Did you ever see that shit
when they did that whole thing?
I'm chromatic in the Ndaa. Tall is like,
one of them was like fucking slower,
like the,
the fucking white dude in the NBA and
one of them was a little bit quicker,
a little bit smarter.
So they fucking did this shit where like
when they would show him like taking
down some prehistoric bison, like the
fucking little smarter ones, you know,
they could fucking, you know, that
that Shit, they could slip a punch,
they could throw a goddamn spear.
They could do,
they could do it from a fucking distance.
Like this fucking jackass. He wasn't,
he was too close to the God damned cage.
The fucking Chromatin is whatever.
The dumber ones they would like
fucking day would just brute strength.
They would fucking run and try to tackle
the thing and someone would, you know,
separate this shoulder,
a break,
an elbow and there's nobody
around is set that shit.
Every step in your fucking non-existence
shoes and your big stupid prehistoric.
It's just shoving that pain shoot
through your body. I edge can't imagine.
I can't imagine sitting there looking
out of a cave in everything is that much
faster than me and I don't have a
fucking door. I don't have a gun.
You just must be just sitting here like a,
and he can't really communicate to the
other person because language hasn't been
developed yet. So you just having
that. What the fuck? Look on your face.
That was probably one of the
first phrases invented like,
are you shitting me or the Kelly?
Can you fucking believe this?
I Dunno, but God blessed that
dude, you're an animal lover.
I totally know where you're coming from.
But for the love of fucking God,
those things are not your friends.
Okay.
I Dunno. Start p nine dx in and stay away
from that fucking cage. Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine that?
Yeah,
I'm getting dragged away by
two fucking abused chimps.
Then you know, God damn well he saw
that fucking Oprah want episode.
That woman came on with no face. I know.
He was fucking thinking of that shit.
I hate those motherfuckers. You
know what is, I like gorillas.
I hate chimpanzees and I
hate those little monkeys.
The little motherfuckers
that throw this shit at you.
I can't stand those fuckers.
And I hate chimpanzees.
I always hated those motherfuckers. I
didn't know why. And now I know why.
That was my inner fucking whatever
the fuck caveman telling me.
Get the fuck out. Go
back to the cave. Stupid.
I don't trust them. I don't. I
don't trust those fucking things.
You have to go to the
zoo and you just fucking,
you just your eyes meet with like a lion.
Just that fucking look on
their face when they, they,
there's just, it's, I've said this before,
it's like what the same look like
when a hooker looks at you like it's,
it's the real deal.
You know,
this isn't some fucking bullshit.
Flirting, playing hard to get,
get a couple of drinks out of
you. It's, yeah, you got 20 bucks,
I will suck your Dick. What? Ya know,
lions got that same look on their
face. Like, yeah, if you know,
if you weren't in that fucking armored
vehicle or on the other side of this,
yeah. If I was hungry I would eat you
and uh, no matter how much he screamed,
I wouldn't give a shit. It actually excite
me more to rip your fucking head off.
There's no way. There's no
way. There's no fucking way.
Yeah.
That's why I watch all those
animals thinks about, I'm
fascinated and I, and I, I,
I appreciate all those people that put
themselves in harm's way because there's
no other way to really gauge how strong
an animal is until you see it slap
around a human being.
Like,
I can't watch too fucking grizzly bears
wrestle and slap each other. They're,
they're in the same weight class.
You know what I mean?
If I see him bitch slap a human being
and watch the guys head spin around a
couple of times, like, wow.
All right, I get that. I can
now gauge that. Let's like,
yeah, like, like kilometers
versus miles. All right.
I think we killed that subject.
Um, moving along. Holy Fuck.
40 minutes in and we had a bunch
of good emails this week too,
so I got to get to this shit.
All right. Um, by the way,
if you'd like to email me and tell me
to shut the fuck up or ask me a question
or anything,
uh,
the official podcast email
is bill@thefmpodcast.com.
Bill at the capital m,
capital m,
capital p Ahd cast.com.
That's it. All right.
Okay. Here's the first question.
Alcohol. Hey, fuck head.
What's your favorite type of beer?
How often do you drink hard alcohol?
Not sure why I want to know so badly,
but for some reason I do go fuck a pole.
You know,
people,
just because I have an over the top
podcast doesn't mean that I don't have
feelings too.
That was a guy,
like I've been such a country to everybody
written in to me. Like he's like,
all right, I'm going to be a country you
first. So I guess I deserve that. Alright.
What are the questions here? What's your
favorite type of beer? Uh, all depends.
It all depends.
Um,
there's beers that I like cause they
take me back to a fun time in my life.
Michelob light Budweiser every time.
If I haven't had those beers for awhile,
Michelob light is the
first beer I got drunk on.
And Budweiser was the
king of beers and I came,
I was a child of the 80s
where you actually got a
tattoo of the Budweiser label
on your arm.
You know,
I suppose to this fucking shit people
do nowadays with Chinese writing.
And I don't know, that's even old. Um,
so like whenever I drink that shit,
it just takes me back to like a,
when I lived in Massachusetts season
tickets to the patch fucking Bruins,
Boston. Yeah. You know, trying
to fucking get laid, you know,
working in a warehouse, no fucking
debt, you know, all that shit. So,
um, I've tried to snobby beers,
you know, it's, it's funny,
I don't like Belgium beers. I, I'm mind
blue moon, but I don't let the too sweet.
They got that sweet taste in him. I don't
like that. I like beer more with a bite.
I like German beers. Um, yeah,
it all depends.
I had like a fucking major thing with,
with Guinness for the
longest fucking time.
And then I went over to Ireland and
I tried the Guinness over there and I
couldn't tell the difference.
I was like,
I thought it's supposed
to taste better over here.
And I drank it all fucking
week cause I loved it.
And then when I came back to the states
then the shit that they had mistakes
tasted like ass and I've never
kind of been able to go back to it.
So I don't even know if
I answered the question.
And how often do I drink hard alcohol?
Uh, not that much, but when I do,
oh Geez. Um, I like
Scotch. I like whiskey.
I do,
you know,
I saw somebody recently who's
been just drinking nonstop,
like always embraced the lifestyle, you
know, cigar smoking, fucking Whiskey,
drinking hardcore and oh my God,
dude,
you can do that for a little while,
but you do that shit. Dia Fifties, man.
You get like,
you get that your bottom lip always looks
like you just put fucking chap stick
on it, you know? And then you get
this big head. You look like this guy.
He looked like a fucking old woman.
I can't even tell you.
He still has like a great head of hair
and he had like this bad ass rockstar
haircut that was a little short,
but because his head was so fucking big
and its torso was all fucking, you know,
man tit it out.
That's what he looked like.
He looked like an eastern European
60 year old woman. You know,
those women who look like they
could rip a tree out of the ground.
Okay.
I think bill, Maurice said that they asked
him why, uh, he doesn't drink anymore.
He goes, yeah, you know, after
awhile you start like Ted Kennedy.
He's absolutely right. Um, all right.
Beef Kurt and advice for
those of you in the states,
that's a slang for the
Hoo Ha beef curtains.
Do the math. Think about it. All
right, you ready? Okay. Here we go.
Here's the situation. I have a
wonderful girl in my life. Uh, what,
when she does not a fuck.
That's what I'm guessing.
I'm guessing this is where it's going.
I wonderful growing my life.
Great attitude, humor, big tits, nice ass
and a good family. Jesus Christ. Dude,
marry this girl. Sure. It seems
good for now. But I have one issue.
She also has some mean beef
curtains and he put in parentheses,
Pussy Lips just in
case. I didn't know. Uh,
that kind of bug me bug the ever living
shit out of me whenever we get down to
the dirty business.
So much.
So to the point I looked up some cosmetic
surgery that basically gives the beef
curtains a trim job and
beauties the vagina.
While, dude, why? All right. Now
before I read the rest of this,
if you're going to fucking ask
me how to have this conversation,
like listen, love, I love you. I love you,
I love you family. I love you, your heart,
everything. But is there any way
you could trim your beef curtains?
Maybe you can get away with it cause
you've got that cool accent. I Dunno,
but she has it too so she's
not going to give a fuck.
You maybe pull this off with
some foreign chick anyways. Um,
so he looks up cosmetic surgery
to try on a beautiful vagina.
Now I know by now I must sound like a
douchebag focusing on the little things
now because women do that to women.
Focus on little things like that.
That's a serious issue, dude.
Sex is a big fucking thing.
But anyways, he says,
but my thinking is I'm truly
going to pull the trigger.
He spelled it that way and keep this
woman all the myself for the rest of my
life are and I entitled to have a great
looking vantage to look at it for as
long as our bodies don't wrinkle away.
Wow.
I know there's a lot of women are
fucking annoyed by this one. Yeah.
What about your fucking
Dick in your wrinkled balls
once you get a face lift
for your sack there, buddy.
I know they're all saying that.
Um,
how can I ever bring this
option up to her without,
I knew he's going to ask me
without completely destroying
her feelings or making
her hate me for being so pussy conscious.
Thanks for the read.
Now go fuck yourself. All right.
This is a simple one, dude.
There is no fucking way
you can bring that up to her without
absolutely completely destroying her
feeling. So you either need to accept this
or you have to, you have to let her go.
That's it.
I mean, I would think that if you
actually truly cared about this girl,
now all the chicks are going to be like,
oh,
I knew he had a heart underneath
all those c words. Um,
if you truly care about this girl, uh,
I would think that that wouldn't matter.
You know, and if she looks
the way she, she's saying,
you're saying that she looks,
I mean, what, what are we
talking here? Like how,
how far down are these things
hanging as it like, you know,
I mean she got 'em both of
them peers. Could you like
do like, uh, could you like,
oh, it's bad to say, could you be
like, do you like that Olympic?
The fuck is that thing here.
You're on the rings.
Could you do that and still swing
your feet up and not hit her pussy?
Are we talking like it's that bad?
You know if you did the iron cross,
would your head be in her pussy?
Like how far these things hanging down?
Hey now
what's the deal with big gardens?
All right dude, there's no way there's,
there's no fucking way and don't,
don't do that to her because she
can't do anything about that.
If she had a problem with
her fucking vaginal area,
you would have known by now because she
would have been self conscious and she
would have brought it up the way.
Sometimes girls do about parts of their
bodies and they are super self conscious
about their bodies because we're
so fucking visual. All right.
I told you once had, when the
first girls I ever hooked up with,
when I got his shirt off and her bra,
she rolled her eyes and I thought she
was thinking that. I was like, oh my God.
Like I'm not doing it for
like she's rolling her eyes.
Like this guy's lame and I found out later
she was self conscious about the size
of her breasts. So I totally
took it the wrong fucking way.
I made it all about me cause
I'm self-involved. So A. Dot.
Yeah, don't do that tour.
All right.
Either.
You can see that that's when you
just suddenly have in your head.
Either you accept that
shit or you move on,
but there's no reason to hurt this person
because you're a shallow cut like me.
All right. All right. Cheers.
[inaudible] sister. What is it? Sister
sister's a, oh Christ. I can't even
fucking read. You know what it is?
I put it into a different
document and it doesn't show it.
For some reason capital letters don't show
up and it's this new fucking computer.
I'm just not liking it.
I have to read this because I think
this is a funny title. Hang on, hang on,
hang on, hang on. It was funny. It
was it. Hang on, hang on, hang on.
You know what that's from a
long time ago when fucking, uh,
when a Eric Clapton did a unplugged
and they play dead stupid,
wooed you.
No money,
like
9 million times that fucking summer
and you want to kill yourself. But he,
he's got a moment and during that that
is unplugged where you start to song and
he fucks up and he goes, oh, hang
on, hang on, hang on. Hang on.
Some reason that is stuck in a
loop in my head. Anytime I fuck up,
I saw that thing 20 years ago and anytime
I fuck up to this day, I go, hang on,
hang on, hang on. I'm all right.
Sisters a through C IR we go,
uh,
tired of giving
advice to guys with psycho suicidal
girlfriends or people with STDs. Well,
I got something a bit
lighter for few here.
A kind of like the cores light version
of your typical advice. Thank you.
And is perfect for the middle of the
summer. We kicked my feedback on this one.
So I know this lady who
I'd been friends with uh,
for a while now and banged one time.
She's the oldest of three sisters,
so we all call her sister a.
About two years ago I made
out with sister be in a club,
not my initiative, um, and ended up
having sex with there the same night.
Jesus Christ. Dude, I
went out with her. Do,
do they have like that thing on the back
of their SUV where they have the stick
figures of the entire family and you
just slowly keep exiting them out
and the family doesn't
understand if somebody's trying
to kill my daughters. No,
I'm just trying to fuck all of them,
sir. Well, that's a relief. All right.
Um, anyways, I went out
with her for a while. Oh,
this is sister B.
And it was surprisingly not awkward
when we were hanging out all together,
even though everyone knew the situation.
Jesus Christ,
what's southern state are you in sir?
Um,
I'll go fuck yourself people down south.
That was funny. Um, some months later,
sister bea left me for one of her,
one of my friends and got
over it quickly enough. Oh,
when you got over it quickly enough.
And nowadays I'm still in contact with
sister a and B since I'm not the kind of
guy that holds a grudge for that kind of
stuff. Oh, there you go. It's very mature,
which means you really didn't give
a fuck about either one of them.
So why are you going to be all upset?
You know,
like you own their pussy once you fuck
it. I hate when, I hate when guys do that.
Anyways,
recently since sister see started talking
to me more frequently after talking
for a bit,
she said she could pose for me since
I'm a painter and she's a model and a 10
all the fucking way I might
add, oh, you fucking creep.
You fucking creep.
So she was a 10 the whole time.
So basically you're in a holding pattern
banging her oldest sisters waiting
until this girl was of age so he could
fucking painter Jesus Christ. I got to, I,
you know, I might have to
stand up and applaud this one.
This guy is taking it to another level.
This is a fucking epic situation here.
So you go see, here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Do you need my advice?
I need advice from you. How do you
fuck every girl in the same family?
Okay.
Jesus Christ. This is like, you
know how long that's been a,
it's been since it's been a triple
crown winner in horse racing.
The last time someone
won the Kentucky Derby,
the Preakness and the breeders' Cup.
Is that what it is or is that a soccer
match? I don't fucking know. I don't know.
No fucking horse.
Since the late seventies I would
guarantee that it's been since the late
seventies sent somebody
has booze bank three.
I think a lot can do two in one family,
but to get all fucking three,
two,
three,
two is a respectable three is no,
it's beyond respectable. Two. Three. Okay.
Everybody who was three years
in the sporting world do that.
That's a fucking dynasty.
Okay.
You just put yourself in there
with fucking Bill Russell.
You put yourself in there with,
with, with the fucking, uh,
Magic Johnson Lakers. You know,
I wouldn't say the Colby Lakers.
You know, when you go out and you
get Phil Jackson and fucking shack,
then that's that new shift that the
kids like. I don't like that shit. Um,
either way, dude, you're talking
fucking dynasty. Oh wait,
magic never won three in a row, but he
had the Celtics to fuck with named when?
Three out of four years. Give me a
fucking break. Um, so he's Michael Jordan.
There we go. So here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Is it a trap?
Should I try to bang her?
Should I try and bang her too and get a
third strike or keep my dick in my pants
and avoid a potential shit storm?
And if yes,
do you have any tips,
special tips on this special situation?
All my friends are telling me to do so,
but I thought I'd ask him.
We'll refine mine like yourselves
before I did a move. Dude,
you are looking at me like, dude,
you're beyond me right now. Okay?
This is like Bull Durham. I'm, I'm fucking
Kevin Costner. Um, I'm, I'm a lifer.
Okay. You're, you're,
you're going up to the show hidden brand
new balls every fucking day. I will.
I will you tell me. Okay. I never
banked to girls in one fucking family.
You know,
I was psyched if I was able to tag a
couple of friends and we were all hanging
out at a bar one night.
And you get that feeling like I fuck
both of you and you both know it and you
both loved it. I hope. Please,
please tell me you liked it.
Did you like it was I okay? Um, dude,
I think you got to do it. You
got to do it. You know, you,
you've been above board the
whole time, sister. A sister be,
they all fucking knew everything right
now I understand this is a little
delicate. Okay. He's trying to snip the
last wire here. This is the kid sister.
Is it going to blow up in your
fucking face? Uh, it's worth it.
It's worth it. It's worth losing a
couple of limbs and you nose on this one.
You got to do it the fuck. You know, Dude.
What the fuck she says to you? I,
yeah,
you're,
you're a painter all let me take my
clothes off and get paid my fucking Twat.
That's not art too. That's
foreplay. Give me a fucking break.
It'd be one thing if you're
in a classroom of people,
it's just you and she's
standing there naked dude.
That's like one of the tabs they
have had done that porn senate,
that scenario in a porn at Jesus
Christ, you might have fun. A new angle
do. That's phenomenal. That
is fucking phenomenal, dude.
Got To do it.
You got to do it.
Did John Elway retire when he only got
one? He came back for another, right?
Yeah.
You got to do it, dude. Dude, dude,
that's like when Bush
fucking the first Bush.
He stopped and he didn't get Saddam. You
got to go all the way on this one, man.
All right.
You gotta be like Marlon Brando in
fucking apocalypse now. He just, you just,
you just accept the fact you
left the program. All right?
And
I don't care how mad these girls get,
dude,
you are at the precipice of
becoming an absolute fucking legend,
okay?
Legend who, who can, who, who's
gonna be able to talk to? Dude,
there are celebrities who've had orgies,
they've had five on ones and all that
type of Shit, okay? But I guarantee you,
they never fucked three fucking girls
in the same family when they weren't
famous, not famous. You're doing
this shit with the gift of Gab.
Whatever the fuck you're doing, dude,
you do this. You got to write a book.
You gotta write a book that's, you
know, that's what you should do.
Collection of the most amazing pussy
getting stories ever that you can somehow
confirm, all right? And it has
to be none of that bullshit.
The second you get famous, you get
money. That doesn't count, all right?
That's garbage time,
okay?
They put the fucking second team in
there and you just fucking Titone layups.
That's bullshit. I'm talking
about just regular dude. You do.
You talk yourself into it through the,
and you're a fucking legend.
You got to do it. All right.
There's my halftime speech.
I'm going to quote Joe Barton.
Nick quoting John Madden today is going
to be the greatest day of your life,
but only if you win.
Okay?
All right. You got to do it. You got to
fucking do it. All right. Here we go.
Next one. Bill. Fight over.
Picture with you is billion.
My girl and I drove up from San
Francisco to see you in San Jose.
You didn't drive up. You drove down.
If up to you means south. I don't know.
What the fuck are you doing? Um,
and it was awesome. Thank you. Uh,
we were at the show where that lunatic
in the front row was giving you a pastry
or a pumpkin after every fourth joke.
Nah, they were nice. This fucking lady,
just like lady,
she fucking brought it.
She made an ACDC pumpkin.
She,
she made a bunch of muffins and she
brought cookies. It was like every,
I guess I had three jokes about food and
she just sort of brought them up to the
stage. She was nice. I know what you
mean though. It got a little crazy.
But once she had actually,
uh,
made the ACDC Pumpkin anyways, I've
seen you three or four times. Uh,
but this is the first time since I've
been listening to a first time since I've
been listening to the podcast.
So the show over and my girl starts
going on and on about how I need to get a
picture with you. Uh, no one fence bird,
but I don't want a picture with you or
with anyone. I don't know personally.
Well that's cool. He goes, uh,
well Megan, maybe Megan Fox.
That totally makes sense. Um, yeah,
and I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm not offended.
You think like fucking standing there
at the end of the show with people with
the cell phone cameras that they hand
to somebody else and they don't know how
to work them and then they fucking, you
know, even when they hit the right button,
you've got to stand there for like
nine seconds before finally clicks.
It's a nightmare. Um, so I'm glad one
less person I had to do that with.
So he goes, uh, anyways. And
I just feel like I was some,
if I was some pseudo celebrity,
I wouldn't want to be taking
pictures with any dudes though.
Did you have to really bring me down
to fucking earth like that? You can't.
This guy's a fucking cunt. I know
what level I'm at your fucking deck.
You don't need to take
my knees out anyways. Uh,
what does he say? I don't want to take any
pictures with dudes. Just chicks. Yeah,
that does make sense. Is this guy
son? He likes the others guys like,
like trying to be my friend while
he's subtly giving me shit. This is,
I call this the Greg Fitzsimmons.
This is what Greg does.
Greg compliments you and Barry's
the insult in the middle.
He's a five minute for all I know.
Fitzsimmons is do this.
Fitzsimmons wrote this because I think
he realizes that I figured him out.
So he's like, well, now what's
another way I can get him? I know.
I'll send an email and pretend
to be somebody else. Sorry.
That's my conspiracy theory
kicking in. Um, anyways,
that's the whole point, right?
So,
uh,
I go to the bathroom and when I get
back in the line to get a pic with you,
it's about 30 deep.
My girl at this point is still nagging
after I already told her I'm not
interested in taking a picture with
bill burr. Uh, now I got to get it.
Now I've got to turn into an asshole
because she's still nagging me about this.
And I have to certainly say,
I don't want to take a picture.
I'm not waiting in that line. I don't
need you thinking for me. Let's go.
Well, that's what you should do,
but you shouldn't do it with anger.
So we go outside and she starts going on
and on about me being homosexual. Yeah,
that's her logic.
I did wait in line to take a picture
with you so that automatically makes me
quit. Quit. He said in
earned Insert Boston accent.
I just kept asking her why was she
trying to start a fight with me? Uh,
we had a great time and now this,
I told her my hero growing up was Chris
Cornell and I wouldn't even want a
picture with him or an autograph.
I don't understand the desire to bug
complete strangers for a picture or an
autograph. Dude, I totally get this. Uh,
he goes Florentine does it all the time
and brags about her on his podcast,
but he thinks,
uh,
black tubes who keep the tags on their
hats or match their shoes with their hats
is gay. Uh, they're both
gay by the way. Oh, what?
Getting a picture and that dude,
you just took a whole fucking
left turn there he goes,
my girl isn't a fan of yours
and thinks you're a sexist pig,
but you turned her with your
performance in San Jose. So what do you,
what do you make of this billion? Yeah,
that's weird. She didn't even like me.
And then you go there and then she's
demanding that you get a picture.
Am I queer?
Because I didn't want to get in line
and wait for you to take a picture for a
half hour with you. Uh, no you're not.
You're a fucking guy who knows what he
wants. And you wanted, you went there,
you saw the show, you had a good
time. You wanted to fucking leave.
That's what you should have done.
And what's with chicks trying to make
you do shit you don't want to do? Um,
I don't know. You got to ask
them. I have no fucking idea.
Okay.
Because you know what it is. They feel
that they know what's good for you.
They honestly feel that.
And they'll tell it to you with a straight
face and a then all a front. Yeah,
we do.
If you just listen to us [inaudible] like
they think that they have life figured
out and the reality is,
is they have part of life figured out,
you know, and that's why
you need them. You know,
they have that fucking, uh,
let's spruce up the place.
Let's a fucking do some shit that
makes you feel uncomfortable,
but secretly you really want to
fucking do, you know, they know that.
So
what happens is, is I think that they
think that they know that all the time.
So that was some shit where you
like, dude, I don't want to do this.
And she thinks that no, you're just
being a guy right now and this is like,
this is going to go into your,
this is fucking gay zone.
So they think you just be in a fucking
macho guy when they don't realize that
sometimes it's like, no, seriously,
I really don't want to do this.
I really don't want to go to brunch.
I really don't want to go
to your girlfriends fucking
birthday party where we
dress up like it's the 1940s I really,
I honestly, from the bottom of my heart,
I don't want to fucking do this.
I don't secretly long to do this,
but I'm worried that my friends
are gonna make fun of me.
I seriously don't want to fucking
do this. Okay. But the thing is,
this is guy is you're gonna say it
like that and then they go, you know,
you're angry. Why you
being mean to me? Um,
I dunno.
That's why chicks trying to make you do
shit that they don't want you don't want
to do. And also a lot of them are
selfish cons just like us. Um,
and if they want to do something
and they think it's awesome,
they can't figure out why you don't think
that it's awesome. And He, you know,
all right, I think I explained
that 58 fucking times. Um,
and go fuck yourself with a pseudo
celebrity thought that, that,
that was completely unnecessary.
You know,
fucking content that actually hurt my
feelings even though I know it's true.
Yeah.
All right, well here we go. What
do we got a first date and money?
I gotta I gotta step it up here, man.
What time is it? Oh, an hour and four.
I got to get out of this.
Fuck,
I gotta get Outta here. All right.
First, what does a, first of all,
I led the podcast, but blah,
blah, blah. I'm 20 years old.
Still in college and newly single.
I decided to try my hand on dating again.
I met this girl on Facebook.
We message each other for hours before
I decided to ask her out on a date.
She accepted Jesus Christ. Dude,
she's probably sitting there like,
my thumbs are aching. Well, you
fucking ask me out. Uh, she accepted.
We made plans for me to pick her up.
Uh,
this would be the first date I've had
in four months I'd build, replaced with,
which was around 20 minutes from
where I live. We went to the mall,
which is where everyone
basically goes into the weekends.
So I thought that I would, it would be
a good place to go. When we got there,
we would decide. We were deciding on what
to do. That's not a good game plan, dude.
You should know where you're going to go
and what you're going to do just to get
it going. So then she'd do
you feel like, you know,
this guy knows what's what's going on.
All of a sudden you're making decisions
and all of a sudden she's taken her
pants off. That's how it works.
All right? You can't go there.
You can't treat them like peers.
You've got to put them beneath you.
You've got to have him looking at the
floor that way they don't get to say good
night to nobody. What movie?
Pauper. Greenwich village.
I did a bad version of that.
Um, anyways, when we got there,
we were deciding on what to do. I
suggested a, we watch a movie. Uh,
but nothing good was playing.
Say You fucked yourself.
So instead we decided to eat dinner.
Applebee's,
we ate at this restaurant in the mall
and talked about getting to know each
other.
At the end of dinner.
I paid because I was told
the man pays on a first date.
What I wasn't told was whether or
not I should pay for extra stuff.
Oh my God. We started, well, first of all,
you already set a precedence that
you're paying. The second you pay,
you're paying for the whole
fucking evening. Okay.
And fuck all the women right now going,
right? Yes. Right. Go Fuck Yourself.
You fucking free. Cons. Uh,
we started walking around and we go into
a few stores and she starts looking at
things around the store saying,
I wish I had money to do to buy this.
I wish I had enough money to buy that.
So what I did,
because I was trying to be the
gentlemen and impressed her,
was offered to pay for
those things she wanted.
Okay.
Ah, dude. Ah, you just fucked yourself.
She totally doesn't respect you anymore.
You got used.
I ended up buying or some sunglasses,
a shirt address and some shoes and
a necklace on a first date. Dude,
on a first date the first night out
with you, just getting to know you,
you buy her dinner and all this shit.
Cedar relies on the second date.
If it's going to go any further, as you
know, relationship has to move forward.
Let me do you have to buy or even more
shit. All added up to around 120 bucks,
not including the dinner.
After that,
I drove her back to her place
and that was it. Of course it was
okay.
Jesus Christ. You bought her a bunch of
shit like you were already fucking her.
Yeah.
That was like her blowing you and then
asking, can you take me to a movie? Yeah,
yeah, I'll get right on that.
It's not happening anyways.
We'd gone out for more times since then.
Of course she is.
She's trying to get a whole
fucking wardrobe audio and
the only thing I got out
of this girl was a makeout session.
Yeah, that was a sympathy one.
To be honest. I wasn't really expecting
to get anything from this girl.
So why did you buy all this shit?
Dude,
you've got to work on your
self esteem here, man.
You set yourself up to be a SAP and
that's exactly what's happening here.
This is all on you and you have the
power to change this shit. All right.
Take this fucking girl out next
time. Not Her. Somebody else.
Cause you've already ruined it with
this one. Okay, fine. Another girl,
take her out when you take her out.
No,
where the fuck are you going to go and
know what you're going to do. Okay.
And when she goes, no, I wish I
had that. Well, hey, you know,
maybe you ought to work some overtime
this week. You know, don't say that,
but just think that. Go Fuck
Yourself. And uh, you know,
and just be silent when
they say that shit,
then they'll realize they overstepped
some shit and uh, you know,
they probably feel like they got to make
up for it by a maybe given you a handy.
Um, anyways, he,
I'm going to plow through this shit
after telling my friends about the first
date, whoever all my friends
said what I did was wrong.
I shouldn't have done that.
All my lady friends said what I did was
sweet and rare for a guy to do. Yeah.
Because they want us to buy him shit.
It's got me at the crossroad of who to
listen to more listened to the guys on
your team.
Stop going on cross enemy lines and
trying to figure out what the fuck you
supposed to do. All right, fuck all that.
The only time you talked to broads
is if you're trying to, well,
what should I get her for a birthday?
What's some chick shit that you guys like?
That's what you do. Okay. You
don't fucking ask them. You know,
should I spend all my money?
Yeah, that would be sweet.
Okay.
Yeah. Don't listen to them. Listen to
your friends to set you straight, dude.
You dropped 120 fucking bucks
and you didn't even get kissed.
She got everything she wanted.
You didn't get anything.
Okay.
Yeah. Fuck all that dude. Fuck all
that. All right. Don't ask women
advice about fucking
women. Like don't, okay.
Okay.
Immediately you, you're
making it an away game. Okay.
You fucking talk to you guy friends. All
right. And I'm not talking about like,
you know, getting the end
Athol advice cause the guys,
we'll give you stupid fucking
advice to case in point myself.
But like when it comes to shit
like that where you're basically,
when you feel like you went too far,
the women are always going to side
with going too far in their direction.
You know what I mean?
That would be like if a girl came
up to a guy and said, listen,
my boyfriend wants to like,
you know,
possibly bring another girl into the
bedroom. Should I do that? I mean,
what the fuck are you going to say
and what are they going to say?
No, come on. All right, here we go.
Dilemma Bill. Imagine you met a girl.
She's beautiful. Has a great body,
funny and totally into you. I did.
She lives with me. Oh, this
is a mixed of points. Anyways,
the night's going great and you having
a good time together and she goes home
with you. Uh, so back at your place.
You're making out and things are
getting pretty hot and heavy.
She starts to undress and she has great
tits. Oh my God. Then she takes her pants.
Serve eal.
She's wearing an adult diaper.
You have to diaper is unsoiled.
Is it still a deal? Yes, it is.
Absolutely. 100 fucking
percent deal breaker done over.
That's it.
It's over.
I'm thinking you peeing and shitting
and my Dick has a is slumped over and is
like, Bill, you enjoy the rest of your
evening cause I'm calling it a day.
Absolutely a fucking deal breaker.
Apps of Fuckin lutely
cause that's gonna take me,
it takes me immediately back to a
horrifying situation that I had.
I think I told this story before.
I'll tell it really quick cause
I gotta get Outta here. Uh,
hooked up with this girl fucking hot,
sexy fucking super tall like model type
chick to the point where we'd like doggy
style. She had to like fucking like
her, her, her, she was too high.
I'm going to plow through this
because this is disgusting.
If you don't like disgusting stories,
plow through the next fucking 30 seconds.
All right, fast forward to her. Alright,
whatever. So we hooked up and everything.
We started in the living room,
we ended up in the bedroom. Okay.
So you know that shit with his,
like the trail of clothes.
The next morning she's picking up her
stuff. I'm trying to help her out.
I see your little fucking panties there
in the, uh, and the living room. And, um,
I went over to them and,
uh, there was a, uh,
oh, this is, this freaks me out. There
was a fucking, I would say at least
three, two and a half to three inches.
Fucking Skidmark in her fucking panties.
I know. Disgusting. Oh yeah.
So it's a deal breaker.
Listen to the sound of my voice
when I tell that story. It was just,
it was fucking horrific. Alright.
Overrated. Underrated, underrated.
Moving apartment. Okay. Underrated.
Moving apartment at six in the
morning and drinking j a j d at noon,
listening to ACDC on your new balcony
in the sun while looking at all the rest
of the douchebags unpacking their
truck with shit they don't need.
You moved at six in the morning and nobody
complained. What the fuck do you care?
Right. You're moving out.
Um, overrated vacuuming.
Uh, there's no way to do this
without looking at feminine.
Ah,
it's a fucking
great bit, man. You could
actually sell it to a comedian.
You could fucking kill with that. He
goes, you got to limp wristed Lee.
Hold that cord out.
Like tinker bell with a wand.
There's just no manly way to
vacuum. Can't be done. It can't.
That is a woman's job.
It's just fucking over theirs.
It's like wearing an apron.
There's just no way to do it. You,
the only way to wear an apron is a guy is
that it has to be that solid white one.
You have to have all the other white
matching shit like uh, like your,
your, your uh, uh, uh,
a fucking gourmet chef and you have to
be a fat gourmet chef. Other than that,
you look like a Douche.
Um, underrating sweeping,
good old sweeping with a broom.
Possibly saw dust from the,
you just built. You can get out, you can
get your elbows into it. No risk involved.
Yeah. But then you get like that minor
lung cause you kick up all the dust. Um,
I'm actually like a neat freak and messy
and I actually enjoy fucking vacuuming.
But every once in a while I'll walk by
a mirror and I'll see myself and I will
burst out laughing or I'll immediately
get embarrassed thinking of all my
fucking crazy friends suddenly bursting
and seeing me vacuuming and just
trashing me. Unmercifully for like two
hours. All right. Under the losing weight,
once I turned 30, I decided I needed
to get back into shape. I was 300,
a 300 pound tub of shit and even XXL
shirts were starting to feel snug at 300
pounds. Fuck yeah. Jesus Christ. Um,
I haven't even really put on a ton
of a ton of effort into it yet,
but just by lifting
weights every other day,
riding my bike four or five times a week,
and by eating real food,
I've been losing about 10 pounds a month
for the last four months. Good for you,
dude. That's fucking awesome.
I love that shit. Now,
the best part is that for every 10 pounds
I lose the weight of the girls who are
interested goes down by 30 pounds.
Isn't that sad? Poor women, this,
they just don't have enough people
to choose from. That's great too.
That's good for you though. And I was
thinking being older helps somehow to,
maybe it's just knowledge and confidence,
but I get hotter chicks now than I
could when I was 21 and in better shape.
Yeah. Because you know
something that's also this,
this certain women out there that
they find guys that a little fucking
overweight, uh, they find you
less intimidating, you know,
as opposed to some guy standing
there like a shredded a, it's like,
believe it or not,
they actually get intimidated too.
You would think because they have
the fucking balls that they wouldn't,
but some of them dope hour in
60 minutes or running my, Yap.
Look at that.
I almost brought you all the way to
break time or lunchtime by the time I get
this fucking thing up. All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Please keep all the great
emails coming. Uh, once again,
the email is bill at the [inaudible]
podcast.com. Don't take any shit.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.